a cup of tea and family time things
usually taken for granted
not for this man
hijaws hizbullah is home on bail after
spending nearly two years in detention
the lawyer was accused of involvement in
the 2019 easter attacks that killed 269
people
but charged 10 months later under sri
lanka's prevention of terrorism act with
hate speech and creating communal
disharmony
his detention drew local and
international condemnation and demands
for his release the ordinary the normal
pta detainee
has no lawyer
has no media attention has no social
media talking about it is nothing so
then it's a complete
state of hopelessness and that you're in
a
huge legal black hole and that's the
feeling that a lot of these lot of them
have the law also known as the pta
allows for police to detain suspects
without trial
it also lets courts convict suspects
solely based on confessions
many say it's been used to stifle
dissent and crush
opposition
on tuesday the government voted to
change its law
it follows years of pressure from home
and abroad to repeal or change the 43
year old legislation that this amending
legislation strikes a perceptive balance
having regard to all the changes which
have taken place in our country during
the last 43 years
we have whittled down the provisions of
the prevention of terrorism act we have
diminished
its rigidity
in a manner that is appropriate to the
present stage of development of sri
lankan society we have stopped short of
abolishing it all together the tamil
national alliance says the changes don't
go far enough
the most
talked about provision in the pta
the confessions
made to police officers being
admissible as evidence against that
person
and even co-accused
for that matter still remains
you haven't touched it
sumandiran's party has started a
nationwide signature campaign urging the
government to repeal the pta they say
they have collected more than 100 000
signatures so far
the government says the changes are a
substantial improvement of the existing
security law and has dismissed calls for
a full repeal
but the opposition says it's an attempt
to mislead everyone saying the most
worrying sections of the law are still
intact
fernandez al jazeera colombo